[Music]
okay so this uk mother wants the world
to see the video
of her own son being killed by a single
punch oh my god oh no she wants the
world to see it that's everyone to see
what's our reasoning
she wants to show why it's so shitty
he's being shitty you're probably right
yeah i mean as plain as day that's
pretty much what it is i mean that's
what they did it too they remember they
did that to the thai guy and uh the
grandpa in san francisco
some kid ran up to him and punched him
in the face she wants to show everybody
like how this is like such a problem
and uh
at least we can do
so here's one of those situations i was
telling you about like in
places like uk where there's not a lot
of guns and people just sock each other
we're going to watch this guy right here
he's trying to stop a fight someone
behind him punched him and knocks him oh
he's trying to stop a fight and then
they hit him in the back of the head it
wasn't even it didn't even look like a
crazy clown no it's just a sucker punch
from the behind him and it he hit his
head on the ladder oh
yeah see that's the one because he's out
but with that punch he's out and then
when your head your back your head is
like very vulnerable so it hits the
concrete and it's just dead weight
we did a jk news uh
several years back of our friend um um
kim she she passed away that way too
yeah she got into a fight um in santa
ana in a at a club like on the street
like that you know this fist fight with
some girls and then when she fell
her head hit the concrete that way damn
so he can't be fighting the streets man
you don't know what's going to happen
that's why like when people don't really
fight fight like they go like oh no no
man like you know i [ __ ] that guy up
this and i'm like don't you guys think
like death can happen like you're saying
the movies yeah right right right like
like box or whatever or like it doesn't
end there no some people might have
knives some people might have guns but
then like tough people would be like nah
nah man i [ __ ] that guy up in this i'm
like dude you could die i know yeah
just don't know because all it takes
right you watch that video you're like
oh just some guy barely [ __ ] hate him
yeah but
when it's some random guy from the side
he's trying to he's he shoved some guy
over here it's the shots that you don't
see coming those ones that put you out
like that and he's not even looking at
his eye lines so he just gets cracked
and then he falls out you can't brace
for that and and apparently he was just
trying to stop a fight yeah so the
original dude was trying to like stop a
fight between his i think like his
friend and someone else
and then um
the dude just came behind him socked him
and now that guy is guilty of
manslaughter sentenced to 10 years in
prison 10 years huh yeah i mean uk i
know we always think it's going to be
more right we should add a couple more
years for being a coward punching
somebody in the back of the head yeah
yeah is that in the loss i think so
you should be making the laws
you gotta challenge someone sucker
punches or [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah dudes so
the mom said this is mom's actual word
she said i wanted to put it out there
that when my son was killed there was no
fight or words exchanged between them
it's just a [ __ ] all it takes is just
one right yeah so even if that's not
your intention to make that kind of
damage it's like that's what does she
want to do ban like just all punches are
all physical
banned all hands until now until now
punches are very illegal in the uk
we need to control half
hands
hand control guys hand control oh my god
got these semi-automatic hands
oh my god but that's really common
though that [ __ ] happens all the time
that's what i was saying earlier is that
like um that [ __ ] happens here a bunch
of dudes just coming back from the pub
drunk
you know just for no [ __ ] reason suck
somebody there's so many stories like
that of dudes just hitting their head
dead whether they get punched in the
head there's some people i used to work
at this like uh aquatic therapy center
and you see patients all the time where
they'll just pass out they'll just pass
out hit their head and have a tbi oh
they can't walk they're paralyzed
sometimes they you know obviously in
some cases some people end up dead you
know like just from fainting or whatever
just from like they don't know what
happened and then their life is changed
completely forever just from falling
back and hitting their head on something
like you just you you never know when
that [ __ ] could happen so doesn't that
mean we should just walk around with
helmets everywhere we go i like that
idea i mean you can yeah i mean out all
the people here i think i should be
doing it i live a didn't dangerous life
that's like get some helmets all the
districts that this happens they should
just put more like rubbery elasticy
cobblestone so when you fall down you go
blink
exactly just come back up every like
every outdoor place is just gonna be a
giant playground it's like everything is
rubber i'm like this isn't even real i
feel grateful man i remember in fifth
grade i was visiting like a family
friend's house in san jose and then i'm
like oh you guys got video games goes
yeah it's in the closets pull it out i'm
like cool and then [ __ ] had all
the controls all like tangled up i'm
like god damn it so it was like ganking
on and when i yanked on it the nintendo
came
crack
i remember i had like a bump for like
two months
you're like [ __ ] wet bandits i know
dude and it hurt like crazy but i didn't
have any like real negative
repercussions besides that and then
there was a bunch of marbles and he was
like whoa
the pearl necklace got torn up
a little blowtorch set my head off
the toilet
got shocked turned into a skeleton
stupid yeah dude there's it's it's just
crazy that like even if who knows like
if this guy had any intention in his
mind to actually kill the dude
i'd like to think not why did he even
punch him in the front i just wanted to
like feel like well i mean if you're
already punching someone in that
situation where they're not even [ __ ]
looking at you yeah you're just trying
to fly that's why you gotta mind your
own business right he's just like
i'm so bad back my boy uh
this is the guy that did it
oh man
his life ruined too for something was
just stupid [ __ ] 25
he's is he is he considered a chav i
don't know
oh yeah explain what chav is uh i think
that's the jersey shore the jersey shore
of the uk i guess
that's chavs i don't know no i don't
know
he would be
looks like it yeah he's a little hoodie
he's a little hooligan
yeah man it's uh it's super sad that
that's something and you would think
like
i mean this is happening a lot in places
that are
less likely to have guns yeah yeah yeah
i think
well places that don't have like that
much gun they do a lot that is better
there's like a lot of fist fights yeah
yeah yeah
because you know like
iron ireland's known for a lot of
drinking and fist fighting you know
but so is hawaii so like yeah
and they both don't have that many guns
there violence finds a way exactly like
violence is that's just always gonna
happen though
you're never gonna stop this [ __ ] from
happening but you could spread a little
bit awareness and more understanding of
like this is the potential if you're
ready to fight if you're if you're gonna
fight somebody in the streets or
anything like that just be ready to die
always but the thing is the guy wasn't
even looking for a fight he was trying
to stop a fight and then some asian dude
recently got stabbed up too
because he was trying to stop a fight
the 7-eleven one yeah yeah he was trying
he's a jiu jitsu dude and he was trying
to stop a fight and then in the middle
of that uh he got stabbed
so like a lot of people that he got
killed huh yeah that's why a lot of the
times people like why don't people do
anything and i'm like that's why
you can't guarantee that uh their safety
yeah and their bravery sometimes comes
with the consequence you know so not
everyone's like ready to just dive in
and give their life up to like you know
yeah you think you're steven seagal bro
yeah i do but
did you teach self-defense for like
situations uh not really the thing about
self-defense is like
it doesn't work people could correct me
if i'm wrong like but my overall
understanding of self-defense and how i
look at it is it's like there's a guy
named tony blauer who's like known in
the self-defense world and he's like the
guy he's just a spear system the spear
system and it's he's very like everyone
hires him to teach self-defense what's
spear system i don't know what it is
exactly like it's like a military
combatives course got it okay but when
he's talking about like civilians
that are getting into uh self-defense
situations it's always
find a way to get the [ __ ] out of there
yeah that's the best part
yeah if you have to fight for your life
you're already too late like because
there's gonna be a situation where you
have to fight for your life then he
teaches you how to be able to get out of
those situations but then again it
always ends up with getting the [ __ ] out
of there because there's too many
variables that you can't control and
even if you're a jiu jitsu brown belt or
whatever like you said earlier it
doesn't defend against knives guns yeah
like you could you could think you're
you could beat up all the guys in your
gym but
if somebody has a knife or a gun that
[ __ ] doesn't really matter like yeah
some guys are successful with stopping
it but it's also a skill that you have
to be practicing all the time you know
it's not something that you just do yeah
all you remember yeah like just because
you trained it once because some of
these like self-defense classes that i
see people teach like it's good that
some people know something right but if
there's not continual practice and
application then have it think about the
time where your heart rate your heart's
beating out of your [ __ ] chest and
you really feel like you're in danger
you think you're going to be able to
pull that off in that moment
yeah yeah you see that
you extrapolate that to like the ufc
right these guys are trained fighters
they know that on this day i'm going to
fight this person
and they dedicate their whole life to
fighting but just because they train all
that that time does not mean that
they're going to
take all those skills that they've
learned and be able to perform in that
high anxiety state when there's a gun on
their head yeah or even even in the
context of the ufc fight right some guys
just don't perform well because there's
so much anxiety it's tension stress and
that
depletes how well you could perform in
some of these situations you know what's
different that like i've noticed is that
like
out of all the times i mean as guys we
get into the situation all the time
where there's actually a defining moment
in a conversation with another dude
where you can make the choice to not
fight yeah like there's always that like
square off yeah and we've seen it
[ __ ] a million times but for women
that [ __ ] does not exist they are just
constantly
in danger there's no like this to a girl
if you're an assailant that's a man
what's what's the
solution to get out of that because like
for men it's like yeah just [ __ ] exit
the situation i mean
in most cases women are preyed upon like
it's it's super rare that the women
women are aggressors and that in most
victims of crime it's men and women done
by men right but then in in the
equalizer i think is usually guns yeah
that or training too like if they
actually trained
like yourself for all women's in general
i always like i always tell my girl i
always tell everyone that i know like
you should have some sort of training
like you didn't tell me
tell her
no but in general though like like all
women should have something like they
should know something whether it's jitsu
whatever the case the thing is
you can teach someone but like you said
can they execute of course but like you
know like all those coupons for
everybody though but like but for
fighter if we get into fight or flight
right it's like should a person hold a
gun if they can't even execute it that's
yeah yeah but that's that's a decision
for that pre-existing like uh i guess
protocol like in your mind for like
situations like that
teeth
yeah nails
you got to fight but also fight or
flight
is trainable
so some like uh someone's like someone
might be more on the timid end but
through constant in like comfort in the
discomfort they will start to become
they can go oh okay cool this is i don't
always have to feel like i have to
retreat or whatever like if i ran a
school's pe program i would have like
girls start doing jiu jitsu when they're
just wrestling that's dope yeah like
learning how to wrestle and slowly by
the time you're 13 or whatever you get
like your blue belt or whatever blue
belt equivalent so like all the chicks
feel very empowered you know yeah but
education is always way better than
unawareness right so like when you when
you have so first step is situational
awareness that's going to keep you hell
out of trouble
having those spidey senses right because
like if you grew up in dangerous
neighborhoods or whatever like you kind
of know you know the signs that doesn't
look good i'ma stay away and not even go
down that street right but then if you
grew up in a nice neighborhood you don't
see the dangers it's true so like even
when i'm traveling like in like like
into different countries i didn't grow
up in this country so everything looks
safe or everything looks chill but they
might be like don't go in that
neighborhood and i'm like why it just
looks normal to me but it's different
right and i feel like that's what
happens when people come to the states
too they don't know yeah they don't know
like they're going into dangerous places
i'm gonna stage from other countries
because they don't [ __ ] have any clue
how it goes good bad good bad good bad
block block block block yeah and then
they'll they'll think i don't need to
rent the car i can just like walk or
take them well for uh for ellie
especially for sure yeah you come to
hollywood and they go to like hollywood
highland all these nice oh we could just
walk over to this place like no you're
gonna take a bus and a homeless man's
jacking off and taking a dump
you